- Hey, it's me Gina.
I'm here with Queer Eye's
Tan who's flown over
from the States to talk
everything British.
(theme music)
What was the biggest culture
shock or the hardest thing
to get adjusted to when you moved?
- Easy, driving on the
wrong side of the road.
And I'm using my words correctly,
We drive on the correct side
of the road, the left side.
- Exactly.
(laughs)
Which British stereotypes
do you have to get Americans to overcome?
- That we are always polite,
that we are passive-aggressive,
and that we don't swear.
Every time I just think, how
are we not used to this yet,
my husband?
- My husband. (laughs)
- Well, it's been 11 years.
- And what stereotypes have
you learned to discount
about Americans?
- That they're phony.
They seem so cheesy that I
assumed that it was an act,
but they're not.
Most Americans I meet,
they're really friendly
and engaging and truly do
wanna know about your life.
It's lovely.
- But loud.
- Very loud, but I think that
there are just so many of them
and it's such a large country
that they've just learned
that that's how they are heard.
- I don't think it's actually
a bad way to be at all.
(laughs)
- I mean I've become louder
ever since I got out there.
I just need my opinion to be heard,
so I'm gonna speak loudly now.
- I think I'd fit right
in with it. (laughs)
- Yeah, but no, but I
love that you're the one
who is saying that they're loud.
- I'm quite (mumbles).
- Ha, ha, I've noticed.
- Which is better, American
cookies or British biscuits?
- Oh, British biscuits.
- [Gina] Yeah, I agree.
I was so worried you were
gonna say the cookies.
- I love a hobnob so much.
- Ooh, good choice.
- What's your biscuit of choice?
- You know what, custard cream?
Is that all right?
- I love a custard cream.
- [Gina] I love custard creams.
- And also a Bourbon.
- I'm out, I'm so sorry.
(gasps)
I don't like Bourbons.
What, the chocolate tastes weird.
- It does taste weird.
It absolutely tastes weird, it
doesn't taste like chocolate,
but it's so good.
Ooh, and have you also tried a fig roll?
- Ooh, yeah, I have but you're giving me.
That's like Grandpop biscuit, no?
- I know, I'm older than you.
(laughs)
- I'm just saying. (laughs)
- Shady bitch.
- Tell me your opinions on American gravy.
- I, whenever I'm in
England, when I go back home
I often will bring an empty suitcase
and I will fill it with Bisto and stuffing
and all those things that I
still don't get back home.
- British fashion or American fashion.
- Ooh, British.
And the reason why I say British
is because our High Street is wicked.
Wicked, wicked.
- Do you have a favorite High Street shop?
Which one would you go for?
- Oh God, that's a tough question.
Bershka.
- [Gina] Ooh!
- I love Bershka.
- That was a plot twist,
I didn't think you were gonna say Bershka.
- I love Bershka.
- Wasn't about that, okay, yeah.
- Do you like Bershka.
- I do like Bershka.
But I find that a few people say that.
- When I wear something from Bershka,
I don't see everybody else in it.
Like I literally, legitimately
twice have worn Bershka
on a red carpet and people think
it's something super fancy.
But no, it costs like 25 quid.
- Oh my goodness.
- Yeah, I mean don't them at the time.
But later on if somebody asks.
- Where would you tell
an American friend to go
if they had a week in the UK?
- As much as I love London,
probably not London because
I think you can get this vibe
in many other capital cities.
I would suggest going up north.
I'd suggest hitting up
Manchester for the music scene.
York for just the
experience, the Cotswolds,
the lake district.
There's so much more to England
than what we see in global press or media.
It's not just London.